et on va plus loin sur ce pays HD
d'agglopolis avec notre invité ce soir
on sort Christophe degréuel bonsoir
Président d'aggopolis on l'a vu 43
communes concernées dont Blois par ce
document d'urbanisme qui organise en
gros la vie quotidienne c'est
d'actualité comment l'homme et la nature
peuvent coexister de façon harmonieuse
et ses équilibre que recherche ce
document urbanistique tout à fait à
Blois nous aimons l'équilibre
l'équilibre entre la ville et la
campagne l'équilibre entre le patrimoine
bâti architectural et la nature c'est ce
qui fait la beauté de nos paysages
objectif en toile de fond c'est de
continuer d'attirer de nouveaux
habitants tout en leur disant attention
la maison sur un terrain de 2500 mètres
carrés c'est terminé oui il y a une
croissance démographique on fait des
enfants il y a des nouveaux habitants
qui arrivent et il faut inventer un
nouveau modèle de construction il faut
être beaucoup plus sobre sur le plan de
la consommation foncière et puis il faut
aussi construire différemment
effectivement le modèle du pavillon au
milieu de la parcelle de 500 mètres
carrés ce ne sera plus possible alors le
pui fixe notamment le nombre de
logements qui doivent être construits
surtout leur répartition dans
l'agglomération en équilibre très
important pour l'attractivité de blog
mais aussi c'est flux de circulation
c'est pas fait par hasard tout à fait
nous avons choisi de faire un plan local
d'urbanisme intercommunal habitat et
déplacement ça veut dire que au cœur de
notre document la question des mobilités
domicile travail et structurantes et
donc nous pensons que aux alentours de
70% de la croissance doit se faire sur
le cœur d'agglomération 20% sur les
Bours j'allais dire d'équilibre et puis
10% dans les autres communes rurales
c'est le respect de la démographie c'est
le respect des équilibres qui existent
déjà équilibré équilibré également pour
les zones rurales en périphérie de Blois
justement tout à fait puisque j'allais
dire la Gâtine tourangelle et dans
l'agglomération de Blois la Sologne
viticole aussi des zones périurbaines et
nous sommes très attachés à ce que
chaque commune trouve sa place nous
sommes très attachés à ce que les 43
communes puissent se développer des
espaces verts vont être protégés
préservés à l'inverse est-ce qu'il est
prévu aussi de réduire certains espaces
artificialisés pour recréer nos espaces
verts alors c'est le grand débat le
débat c'est la sobriété foncière il faut
préserver les terres agricoles naturels
et forestière c'est un enjeu majeur à
l'échelle du pays donc un enjeu majeur à
l'échelle du Val de Loire il en va tout
simplement de notre souveraineté
alimentaire la politique des transports
aussi et dans ce document l'objectif
c'est 44% c'est précis de déplacement à
pied ou à vélo d'ici 2037 c'est-à-dire
que si on ajoute les transports en
commun quasiment plus personne circulera
en voiture alors moi je ne suis pas un
adversaire obstiné de la voiture ce que
je combats c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'auto-solisme c'est-à-dire
l'utilisation de la voiture tout seul il
faut penser
partage il faut s'en il faut penser
covoiturage mais en même temps ces là
que vous venez de citer c'est des
moyennes à l'échelle de l'agglomération
il est évident que en coeur
d'agglomération à Blois et dans les
communes de la première couronne c'est
beaucoup plus facile de se déplacer en
vélo par les transports en commun parce
qu'il y a densité si vous habitez à
saint-cyr-du-gault ou si vous habitez à
120 évidemment le recours à la voiture
sera toujours indispensable un document
qui protège aussi il y a eu énormément
de problèmes à cause des mouvements
argileux qui ont fissuré un certain
nombre de maisons les nouvelles
constructions devront être devront
répondre pardon à certaines normes oui
tout à fait nous avons dans cette partie
de l'agglomération un vrai problème avec
les terres argileuses les terres
argileuses sont soumis aux problèmes du
retrait gonflement des argiles et ce
phénomène de retrait gonflement
fragilise les maisons mais toutes les
maisons ça peut être des maisons très
récentes comme des maisons anciennes
c'est un phénomène très complexe dans
notre document d'urbanisme nous rendons
obligatoires l'étude de sol pour être en
capacité de dire au constructeur au
futur propriétaire au futur locataires
voilà si vous voulez construire une
maison sur ce terrain avec des risques
argileux et bien il faut que les
fondations soient suffisamment fortes en
un mot est-ce que ce pluh HD est figé ce
qui est aussi des risques de
contestation qui pourrait faire que
voilà il soit modifié alors c'est un
document qui a vocation à vivre sur 15
ans 2022
2037 voilà c'est un document qui va
évoluer qui pourrait être modifié quand
il y aura des motifs valables évidemment
pour tenir compte de la réalité donc
voilà c'est un document vivant merci
beaucoup Christophe degruel président
d'agglopolis est devenu ce soir nous
parler du PLU HD merci beaucoup merci